but we begin with a brutal storm system
battering people across much of the
country in the South take a look at this
Devastation in Louisiana from multiple
tornadoes at least two people were
killed those pitchers are from
Farmerville in the northern part of
Louisiana and that's where Elise Preston
is now Elise good morning
good morning Nate at least 30 people are
injured and two are still missing here
in Louisiana after an outbreak move
through the area this apartment unit
behind me is destroyed it's just one of
many buildings in the region completely
torn apart by storms
would you survive the tornado bro this
is my house it's gone a deadly tornado
devastated the community near Four Forks
Louisiana late Tuesday watched you pick
my truck a truck trailer and throw it in
there I was standing on the back porch
when it come right through here as it
tore through the region ripping apart
businesses and tearing through dozens of
homes we got in the shower like I said
and then all of a sudden by the time we
got hunkered down here it was gone the
roof was gone and you know they always
say that you're a train coming well this
was a big train to come through here
police say that a tornado killed a
mother and child who were discovered
near debris hours after the Twister left
the area unrecognizable further north
nearly 25 people were injured when a
twister leveled a neighborhood in
Farmerville Louisiana tornado
Heavy Rain strong winds and at least
nine confirmed tornadoes swept across
the South including Oklahoma and Texas
earlier Tuesday
oh my gosh
yeah that's a nasty one near Dallas that
is getting big drivers scrambled when a
tornado crossed the highway in front of
them in Oklahoma a trail of Destruction
this home took a direct hit
here and it is like I said it is pretty
much destroyed I'm actually surprised no
one was injured like I said you can
totally see the house and it's destroyed
and I'm glad everybody was okay that
string of tornado is part of this same
system as the dangerous blizzard that's
sweeping Across the Western half of the
country
Colorado digs out a hazardous
combination of snow and wind shut down
most of the roadways in western Nebraska
the storm now moves East and takes aim
at the plains next
parts of Colorado were buried under snow
drifts South Florida five heat four to
five feet high here in Farmville
officers say people two people are still
in critical condition and those officers
tell CBS News this is the worst they've
seen in their Parish in 17 years Gail
police thank you it sounds like the
Danger's not over there yet